in this portion of our world views and
values class we're now going to look at
another early modern philosopher this
this time a British person named Thomas
Hobbes and we're gonna look at one of
his works he wrote quite a few other
books as well but we're gonna look at
the one that's considered to be his
masterwork the one that has made the
greatest impact on the history of ideas
and indeed on on modern culture in
general and it's called Leviathan now
we're only going to look at certain
sections of it in part because it's a
massive work and we don't have the time
to go into it probably take a whole
semester to go through the entirety of
the work in the detail it requires but
also because we want to focus in on the
portions that have to do most with the
great themes of this class which are
human nature human society and the
reality that encompasses both of them in
which we find human beings so as usual
with all of these works we want to pay
very close attention to three main
things as we're going into them one of
them is the literary genre of the work
the other that we have to pay close
attention to it's very important in the
case of this work is historical context
and then we'll talk about several of the
main themes that you should be attentive
to you should be able to look out for as
we go through the via Thun what are the
most important things that you need to
know about the literary genre of
Leviathan so you can take that into
account as you're reading the work I'm
going to tell you a few things about it
one thing I want to say right at the
beginning though is that we are looking
at excerpts from the work so we're not
looking at the work in its totality so
some of what I'm gonna say here might
strike you as a little bit off but if
you were to look at the whole work in
which you know the portions that we're
looking at are coming from this would
make complete sense to you so the very
first thing that I need to say and the
most important thing is that what Hobbes
is writing here is a philosophical and
indeed an attempt to be scientific
treaty's now when we've used that term
treaties what we mean is a very
systematic comprehensive work that is
going through you know part by part by
part subject matter by subject matter in
a coherent orderly way trying to bring
everything together and if you looked at
Hobbes Leviathan as a whole you would
see that it has all sorts of chapters
covering all sorts of topics and it's
it's done in what Hobbes wants to be a
proper ordering of things and he's
trying to provide you with you might say
a one-stop shop in a book of philosophy
that can cover everything that's
important to to talk about at least as
far as the main topics that he's
interested in which are political and
moral philosophy but you're gonna notice
that in this this treatise he's not just
gonna stick to ethics or moral
philosophy or political or social
philosophy he's also going to cover a
lot of other ground because he thinks
that those things are important so he's
going to talk about what we call
epistemology or you know the theory of
knowledge or a theory of what truth
means or you know being able to
distinguish between different forms of
knowledge you know how the senses are
connected with thought are connected
with memory are connected with
imagination and who's who's theory is we
should pay attention to and who's we
should dismiss he's also going to be
connecting this up with an underlying
metaphysics a theory of what is most
real we're gonna talk about that in a
moment so these are all gonna coincide
with each other and he's putting out a
theory where he's attempting to be the
person who once and for all
provides a truly systematic scientific
viewpoint on things in part because he
thinks nobody else has done it up until
his time now another thing that I do
have to tell you about this that you're
gonna want to pay attention to going on
going going in very early on is that
Hobbes is writing in the 16th century
but unlike many of the other people that
we've read so far he is writing in
English
he is one of the early modern English
writers and there's a few things that
you need to know about the way in which
they wrote back then that will help you
out one is that they didn't spell things
exactly the same way that we did and so
if you look at certain versions of
Thomas Hobbes work you'll see you know
we spelled W EE and not meaning we
little but we as in you and me together
you're gonna see a lot of what we call
unusual orthography now in the versions
of the text that we're going to use
we're looking at a more modernized
version of it but the the syntax the
grammar the the articulation the style
is also a rather from our perspective
rather archaic way of speaking so he's
going to use words that you're going to
recognize but they might be used in ways
that are a little bit different than
you're used to seeing them so you want
to pay close attention to what's being
sent don't automatically assume that you
know just because it's written in
English exactly what Hobbes is saying
approach this as you would a play by
Shakespeare which is you know not not
exactly the same time but you know
roughly in the same time period you want
to to read through these things
carefully in seventeenth eighteenth even
19th century English as opposed to the
way that people often like to write in
the 20th century and today it was quite
common to have complex thoughts ordered
in a paragraph and there was a lot of
attention to the structure of thought
that was going on there so Hobbes
himself is doing that you don't want to
try to read through this very quickly
you want to pay very close attention and
read through it slowly even meditatively
that way you'll get everything out of it
that you can another thing that I do
want to point out and this is probably
the last thing that needs to be said
about genre is that in a philosophical
treatise one of the things that you're
going to do
is engage other possible viewpoints
either present viewpoints or passive you
points or even just viewpoints that you
think you might be encountering in the
future and Hobbes is attempting to do
that so you're gonna see him talking for
example about the school men those were
the the establishment of the the English
Academy of his day the Scholastic
philosophers who were by and large
losing their their their intellectual
influence and their role in the culture
but were still quite powerful in Hobbes
this time Hobbes is setting himself up
as a critic and even an enemy of them so
he's going to be very critical of their
point of view and you might say why is
he criticizing them because he thought
that was important at the time I think
you can probably disregard these
references as you're reading it today
because there aren't a lot of school men
around but if you want to understand the
full context of what Hobbes is talking
about it's important to look at those so
that's what you need to know about genre
now what is it helpful for you to know
or to take into account as far as
historical context goes we can say much
of the same things of Hobbes as we could
say about Descartes or other of his
early modern contemporaries and as a
matter of fact Hobbes really in many
respects can share with the cart the
title the father of modern philosophy
because Descartes is in some respects a
father of modern philosophy as far as
metaphysics and epistemology goes
setting the agenda you know giving some
some basic ideas that are going to be
engaged with my others Hobbes is doing
that in terms of ethics and political
philosophy and also if you pay close
attention in terms of metaphysics as
well and so Hobbes is is at the
beginning of a really interesting era in
the field of ideas but there's also a
lot that's going on in the broader world
in which ideas have a major role in
deena a revolutionary role and a a
troubling rule that Hobbes is going to
be quite concerned with
Hobbs is born in in 1588 and he's gonna
die in 1679 so he spans roughly and
almost you know an entire century it's
it's not quite a century but it's it's
quite a while and he is born prematurely
because his mother here is the news
about the Spanish Armada that's about to
invade England we'll talk just a little
bit about what that means in a second
but what I want to clue you into is this
really lapidary phrase that has been
used since then Hobbes says in his own
typical laconic way that he was born a
twin to fear that is his mother was in
fear at the time and that's why he was
born early and then Hobbes himself is
born so he's a child of his time he's
not only a child of his mother he's a
child of the fear of his his time of an
era of uncertainty an era of danger and
era of conflict the Spanish Armada was
set to invade England it was a gigantic
fleet and it carried not only you know
cannons and things like that but a lot
of soldiers this was the the last
serious attempt of an invader to try to
invade Britain itself and it might have
succeeded had the fleet not foundered in
the middle of a storm so you know the
English were really quite worried about
this and why was the Armada invading
England well one of the things that was
going on was Europe had broken apart not
only into separate kingdoms because
those existed before but in two separate
interpretations of the Christian
religion this is in the middle of the
Protestant Reformation in Protestants
and Catholics were fighting with each
other some countries were explicitly
aligned with the Catholic Church like
Spain and France although France was in
the middle of the conflict between
Protestants and Catholics for a long
time England was a Protestant country
because King Henry the Eighth had in
effect nationalized the British Church
and declared himself for the Protestant
side
Germany was divided between Catholics
and Protestants Sweden had B which was a
major power at that time had gone
Protestant Italy of course was was
Catholic ball though Italy was divided
into a number of states Austria was
Catholic there were a lot of different
you know developments going on at that
time they were they're quite important
and so we can talk about religious
conflict as something very significant
we can also talk about a lot of other
kinds of conflict that are often
overlapping with or coinciding with
religious conflict the religious
conflict by the way was not just between
Catholic and Protestant it was also
between Catholic and Protestant and
other Protestant and other Protestant
from the Protestant Reformation very
quickly breaks into a number of
different denominational families or
traditions so the Calvinists were just
as opposed to the Lutheran's as they
were to the Catholics the Anabaptist
from which we get the Mennonites and the
Amish day were you know a branch that
was getting essentially persecuted by
everybody
and we can say a lot about other things
along those lines but I don't want to go
too deep into the detail because I want
to talk about some of the other forms of
conflict that we're going on there was
also national conflict sometimes you
know this the the Wars of Religion and
there were indeed wars that were fought
on the basis of religion provided a
pretext for different countries to to
consolidate their own power France was
particularly given to this not so much
in Hobbes's time but a little bit later
as we're going to see England of course
you know the the King had nationalized
the church so that that you know allowed
him to do things like close all the
monasteries take all their wealth
distribute it to people that he liked to
go after people who who remained
Catholic in the country as well he
didn't do that so much but but some of
the successors did that so there was
there was a lot of intra national
conflict as well and there was conflict
within nations and some of that was was
fought on on denominational
but quite a lot of it had to do with
what we can call class lines there's a
lot of economic transformations that are
taking place during this time some of
these involve dislocations so you know
the prospects for the peasants become
bad in some areas and then the peasants
are prone to say things like well this
system is really out of whack we got to
change this things need to to be
affected and usually the other social
classes don't like that at the same time
we're seeing the rise of the bourgeoisie
the rise of originally the burghers of
people from the towns the rise of them
took the positions of prominence through
trade in part because you know at this
time they works
the Europeans were expanding trade to
the newly discovered from the European
perspective of course America's expanded
trade throughout Africa expand a trade
with with Asia and there were a lot of
new new you know developments that were
taking place because of this a lot of
economic changes so some people are
rising the traditional nobility are
finding their power in many respects
hemmed in and curbed not only by the
rise of the new rich the bourgeoisie but
also because the the aristocrats tended
to be troublesome they tended to make a
lot of conflict on their own within a
kingdom because they liked running their
own show and the Kings who are now newly
powerful try to prevent that they say
you know you got to rein this in we're
you know we'll let you do military
campaigns but no more of this fighting
amongst yourselves so a lot of those
sorts of transformations are taking
place
Hobbes himself is going to be not only
witnessing this as a spectator on the
scene but he's also going to be affected
by this as an English Hunt England is
going to go through a civil war which
Hobbes is going to write a history of in
one of his other works that the hamath
and I'll talk more about that brilliant
work in in a few minutes
Hobbes is going to end up you know
siding with absolute monarchy in Part B
because he sees what happens when
factions are fighting with each other
you know the the factions that at first
seemed to be you know the only games in
town they fight with each other once
they become weakened enough somebody
else is going to come in from the
outside and take over and that's what
ended up happening under the Puritans
and Oliver Cromwell Oliver Cromwell in
effect produces the first totalitarian
state in modern Europe under the
Protectorate and a lot and that's not
only bad for the English in many
respects bad for the Irish as well
because you know a lot of things happen
in what was seen as a colony at the time
in any case Hobbes is observing all of
this conflict and that's part of what's
motivating him he wants to try to find
some way in which we can not only
understand the conflicts that are taking
place not only judge who's right and
who's wrong but put an end to this kind
of conflict at least within a nation
once and for all and he thinks that
political science is going to make that
possible if it's the right kind of
political science Hobbes himself is born
of a fairly you know common background
his father is most likely a vicar you
know a sort of low ranking Church
official we don't know an awful lot
about his ancestry he eventually becomes
he goes to university where he more or
less pursues his own course of study
because he doesn't really like what
they're doing the school men and he ends
up becoming associated with the
Cavendish family he ends up becoming the
tutor to William Cavendish and then
accompanies him in 1610 on what's called
the Grand Tour a lot of times people
from aristocratic families in order to
round out their education in England
they would send them and they would
travel around Europe and observe human
beings and and you know draw conclusions
and so some while though it's hopefully
not you know engender any any children
but you know they would they kind of
have a good time before they would come
home and settle down as a fully rounded
individual so Hobbes gets to go to Paris
among other places and while he's there
he starts making acquaintances because
there's a really booming intellectual
life going on not just in Paris but you
know with sort of tendrils out to all
sorts of other areas and who's part of
that not only this guy Moran Marcin who
is a major connector of people but also
Rene Descartes and Hobbes ends up
actually writing the third set of
objections to des cartes meditations
this gives you an idea about how
important Hobbes was in the intellectual
culture of the time Descartes really
doesn't like in engaging with Hobbes and
doesn't pursue it much after that
Hobbes tries to write some more to
Descartes and Descartes kind of gives
him the cold shoulder but Hobbes is
becoming established as an important
intellectual figure not only in the
British scene but on the European scene
as well he's also coming into contact
with a a new approach to things the
modern scientific viewpoint on things
which tends to be materialistic tends to
view things in terms of mechanism
dismiss all the notion of like final
causes and intentions in nature you know
get rid of Aristotle we're going for
Galileo instead you know how much can we
mathematize things that's that's what
all of this is about and it's a bold new
venture which is going to be as it turns
out in many respects you know mistaken
about this and that and this but also it
turns out to be very right about a lot
of other things as well you know they're
discovering that gravity works the way
that now we understand it works they're
discovering that this has applications
for ballistics for how you shoot you
know cannonballs out of a cannon and
Hobbes is very impressed by this so
you're gonna see him making reference to
you know discussions about motion and
about sets that's where this this whole
empirical and also rationalist tendency
in Hobbes is is coming from he's also
going to be discussing things like like
natural law and natural rights this is a
another set of ideas that are floating
around in the air because people are
trying to make
out of all the conflicts that are taking
place and being able to say who's the
right and who's the wrong in addition
they have to figure out what are they
going to do with all these natives in
these countries that they're
encountering do they have rights do they
have natural rights you know they don't
seem to be living in the same kind of
Commonwealth's or kingdoms that that
Europeans are how should we understand
them so that Hobbes is trying to make
sense out of that as well
another thing that I should tell you
about about Thomas Hobbes Leviathan is
is probably his most important work it's
the one that cemented his reputation and
also drew a lot of criticisms from many
other thinkers not only in his own time
one guy actually wrote the the hooking
of the Leviathan you know Leviathan is
this great sea creature and so the idea
is you pull it out of the sea by means
of argument but he's also been
criticized you know down through the the
centuries all the way to the present at
the same time a lot of his ideas seem to
have you know a recurring value as we
look at conflict situations and how we
should deal with them now
Hobbes wrote a number of other works
he wrote a trilogy on the citizen on
body and the elements of law much of
which actually is going to show up in
Leviathan and these tended to get
published without his permission he
would circulate works among the the
other people who were interested in this
sort of thing and then somebody would
without his permission publish it and
then you know Thomas Hobbes would quite
often get criticized by somebody who
really didn't have any business reading
the work because Hobbes had authorized
it he wrote a number of other works like
that as well where you know it'd be
circulated get published somebody and
say aha see look at this guy and Hobbes
would be like man I I you know I didn't
want that to be public public you know
discussion at this point in time but
that happened Hobbes also engaged
interestingly enough in translation work
one of the works that he translates very
early on what you can tell has an
important influence on and if you
rabbit is through Citadis history of the
Peloponnesian War a time when things
were breaking down in the Greek world
and people were acting pretty badly in
relation to each other and it looked
like force and fraud were much more
powerful than law or or right
later on in his life he's going to
translate Homer's Odyssey and Iliad and
he also you know engages in some
discussion of rhetoric he's sort of a
Renaissance man after of course the
Renaissance because we're talking about
the early modern period but a
Renaissance man in the idea in the sense
that he he understood and contributed to
a lot of different fields so that's
probably enough Oh before I finished one
other work that I mentioned I would tell
you about behemoth so Leviathan is one
biblical creature that the hem a--the is
another these are both mentioned in the
book of Job and the Leviathan is Hobbes
theoretical work where he's talking
about how societies work how they break
down what human nature is like all these
sorts of things from a theoretical
perspective with some historical
discussion but not an awful lot the hem
ahthe is the historical application of
Leviathan and it discusses the breakdown
in in civil order in British society
leading to a civil war and eventually to
the the takeover by the the Puritans and
and Cromwell and all the things that
ensue because of that so behemoth is is
actually well worth reading if you're
interested in seeing how Hobbes got his
ideas and how his ideas would play out
so that's that's enough about historical
context I think what are a few of the
really major themes that you should be
on the lookout for that are running
throughout this work that are the things
we want to pay close attention to in
Thomas Hobbes perspective well from the
very beginning you can say that
Hobbs is adopting a not only materialist
but also mechanist view of nature which
includes human beings so he's gonna say
we don't have anything like a soul or a
mind that's independent of our body all
we really have our bodies and bodies are
indeed mechanisms like this pen you know
they they perform certain tasks it's
based on how they're put together so
that's one key theme another important
feature of Hobbes is work that you're
going to see running throughout as well
is a criticism and rejection of all
previous positions that have been worked
out on that the topics that he is
talking about particularly when it comes
to moral and political philosophy
another thing that's coming out of the
mechanistic and materialist metaphysics
of Hobbes he has is his emphasis on
sense and movement as being what's
fundamental in the workings of the human
mind so he will say for example that
imagination is just decayed sense and
what he means by decayed sense is from
our senses we're perceiving things which
make an impression on our body you know
we would say through our nerves and then
that impression is somehow stored and a
reverberation is still going on within
our our mechanism our brain somehow
going beyond that he also talks about
the interconnection between language and
thought and how much of our thought is
dependent upon our uses of language now
as we move on and we start looking at
how the human being works not just in
terms of thinking but in terms of
feeling and and movement and action we
see that another key theme is what
Hobbes calls endeavor and it's its two
forms in desire and aversion as being
the most basic fundamental movements
that all of our other human action
is ultimately composed of as we go
through looking at how this plays out we
see Hobbes discussing and there's
another important theme the human
passions the different feelings the
different experiences effects that we
have ranging from you know desire to
fear to anger to joy to love to hate to
contempt and all of these can be
understood according to Hobbes according
to this mechanistic view of the human
being something else that's going to go
along with that so here's another key
theme is that moral valuations like good
bad just unjust beautiful ugly useful
and and harmful are not really fixed
they depend on the situation they depend
on the human being who is making the
determination so that there really is
nothing that is fundamentally always
across-the-board good nor is there
anything that's always fundamentally
across-the-board
bad there's a kind of relativism to
Hobbes as morals outside of the civil
society another key idea that you're
going to encounter is the famous state
of nature where life is nasty brutish
and short because there's no governing
authority and anybody does whatever they
want which means that they're going to
come into conflict with each other which
means that we all have to live in
constant fear we can't accomplish
anything anything that we do build or
grow could be taken away from us at any
moment because we can do that to other
people he also discusses three different
sources of conflict in the state of
nature that make it so so dangerous and
these stem from our animal nature but
also our distinctively human nature how
do we get out of that well this is where
Hobbes talks about a social contract and
the transition to what he calls civil
society and in a social contract
we all agreed to give up certain rights
that we have in the state of nature so
that other people will also give up
those rights and we can all live in a
state of more or less harmony with each
other there will still be some
criminality but we can we can get along
with each other something else that's
another key theme are the laws of nature
and these are discovered by reason as
the conditions that we all have to abide
by in order to live in civil society and
to not violate the social contract the
last theme for the readings that we're
looking at that's really key for Hobbes
is what he calls the sovereign and the
sovereign is a person who's placed in a
position of authority above everybody
else and this is necessary in Hobbes
view in order for the social contract to
work in order for us to get out of and
stay out of the state of nature because
without some sort of authority who can
compel us to actually follow through on
our commitments he thinks that human
nature is we will renege on our
commitments and do the wrong thing and
thereby break society down back into the
state of nature if we're rational we
realize Hobbes says that we need an
absolute authority figure over us or
else everything is liable to descend
into chaos so those are the key themes
that you should focus on